reescribe cada fracción con un
denominador de 10 tenemos dos fracciones
tres quintos y siete medios y queremos
tomar sus denominadores de 5 y 2 y
cambiarlos para tener un denominador
común de 10 comencemos con tres quintos
y veamos esto gráficamente usamos este
rectángulo para representar un entero y
para representar tres quintos de este
entero vamos a tener que dividirlo en
cinco en cinco partes iguales dividimos
esto en cinco partes iguales lo mejor
que podamos y aquí tenemos cinco partes
iguales o quintos y para representar
tres quintos vamos a señalar tres de
estas divisiones aquí señalamos tres de
estas cinco divisiones para representar
tres quintos pero decidimos que ya no
queremos quintos
queremos decimos queremos un nuevo
denominador de 10 y ahora para cambiar
esta fracción decimos tenemos que
dividir cada uno
de estos quintos a la mitad y así
duplicar la cantidad de partes y ahora
en lugar de tener cinco partes iguales o
quintos tenemos decimos uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez
así que encontramos una forma de tener
decimos la misma cantidad sigue
representada aquí pero ahora tenemos
decimos así que se duplicó nuestro
denominador lo multiplicamos por dos
pero vean que es lo que pasó con nuestro
numerador en lugar de tener tres pedazos
ahora tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco
seis seis pedazos así que también se
duplicó también se multiplicó por dos
porque si duplicamos todas las piezas
aquellas piezas que resaltamos también
se van a duplicar por lo que ahora
tenemos el doble de piezas resaltadas
por lo que tres quintos se puede
reescribir como seis décimos es igual a
seis décimos y nuevamente no cambiamos
las fracciones aquí
no cambiamos la cantidad que estaba
resaltada tres quintos y seis décimos
representan la misma cantidad
simplemente cambiamos el denominador y
lo reescribimos de una forma diferente
así que tres quintos pueden ser
reescritos en décimos como seis décimos
y ahora para siete medios nuevamente
queremos un denominador de 10 y lo
podemos dibujar o podemos tratar de usar
este patrón de aquí para tratar de
encontrar cómo pasar de medios a décimos
para pasar de quintos a décimos
duplicamos o multiplicamos por 2 y para
pasar de medios a décimos tendríamos que
multiplicar cada una de nuestras piezas
por 5 cada una de nuestras mitades
tendríamos que dividirlas en 5 piezas
por lo que multiplicamos 2 por 5 para
tener 10 y como vemos en el patrón de
aquí arriba si el denominador se
multiplica por cierto número el
numerador también se tiene que
multiplicar por ese número ya que las
piezas resaltadas también tendrán que
dividirse en la misma cantidad así que
multiplicamos nuestros 7 por 5 esto debe
coincidir el numerador y el denominador
deben de multiplicarse por el mismo
número y 7 por 5 es 35 así que 35
décimos es igual a 7 medios así que para
cambiar cada una de estas fracciones y
tener un denominador común de 10 tres
quintos se vuelve seis décimos y siete
medios se vuelve 35 decimos